[Musique]
c'est au musée stella matutina qui a été
présenté la 10e édition des nuits sans
lumières du 5 au 29 avril en présence
d'élus de directeur administratif de
responsables associatifs et de chefs
d'entreprise pensent que c'est une
opération qui était quasi anecdotique à
son origine à laquelle personne ne
croyait on parlait en heure on a parlé
en jour aujourd'hui on en est de mémoire
à 25 nuits concernées et je pense que
l'impact est extrêmement important et si
j'avais un souhait à faire aujourd'hui
c'est que l'ensemble des communes
rejoignent cette manifestation et qu'on
puisse pas pourquoi pas en 2019 on peut
rêver à voir les 24 communes qui
participent à cette opération d'émission
du vêtement l'opération et nuit sans
lumière ont pour objectif de
sensibiliser le public à la pollution
lumineuse ses impacts et les moyens de
les réduire en deux ans le résultat de
la de la consommation a été évité a été
multiplié par 2,5
donc on est passé 300 mégawatts heure de
consommation éviter à avoir presque 800
c'est vous dire effectivement
l'importance que cet événement donc à
amène dans voilà dans son quotidien
depuis quelques années le département de
la réunion participe au nuit sans
lumière
un projet d'envergure qui est dédié à la
conservation des espèces de pétrel
endémique
pour ce qui est les oiseaux nous avons à
la réunion des oiseaux unique au monde
donc qui échoue on me disait tout à
l'heure plus de 2000 échouage en donc ça
veut dire que si l'oiseau n'est pas
repris
il est perdu et le chat ou le chien
mange ali à terme revient chez nous chez
nous la réunion donc la biodiversité
donc nuit sans lumière
mais quand tu as toutes les nuits sont
lumière sont organisées chaque année un
rendez vous à ne pas manquer
[Musique]